I'm on the date right
now, we're on the rooftop-
(hisses)
Stop doing that!
So today I'm going on a
blind date with a vampire.
I'm Anthony Montemarano, I'm part of a,
I guess you'd say clan or a
coven called the Sabretooth Clan
Father Sebastian is a
fang-smith, he made these for me.
My only experience with
vampires is watching Twilight.
I only watched the first two movies
because the second one
was shit, let's be real.
You get a name that relates to something
that you do in life, mine was Onius.
Onius is like a gatherer of people,
it also says that Onius drinks wine,
so I was like yeah, that sounds like me.
Oh my goodness, I don't know
anything about vampires.
I mean I know that they
drink pretty girls' blood,
so, I mean, hey.
Choosing to be a vampire,
I guess you'd say
is like a value system.
I'm not really trying to
be immortal for a guy,
so if that's what he's
expecting on the first date,
it's not gonna happen.
Most of the people I've dated
are non-vampires, I guess.
I'm a very opposites attract kinda guy.
I'm not Bella, I'm sorry.
I'm Anthony.
I'm Selorm, nice to meet you.
Selorm, cool.
That's an interesting name,
love it, love the hair.
Anthony, I like your hair, too.
Yeah, I'm excited to do this.
I don't know what we're
going to be doing, but
I'm sure it'll be fun.
Actually, we're going to be going to
the Museum of Death and then we'll have
an Italian place down the
street called Fabiolus Cucina.
And have some dinner
there and finish her off
here at the building on the
top of the roof with some wine.
Mm, vampires are romantic,
okay, let's do it.
So we started the date by
going to the Museum of Death.
I was really excited
because I kind of have
a small fascination with death.
I was excited to go in, but it was a lot.
Just went in the Museum of Death.
Can't show it on camera.
Museum of Death was interesting.
Pictures of serial killers and
the victims they had slain.
There were real pictures
of bodies inside of there.
The informative things
that were cool was like
the mortician's side of the autopsies
that were performed and how they did it.
So it was a lot especially for a date.
I'd say it's worth checking out, but
it's definitely a lot to read and see.
We're heading to the restaurant now.
All right, so I have questions.
Yeah.
What kind of music do you do?
A couple of bands,
one's called Neon Coven.
C-O-V-E-N.
Kind of like electronic dance rock.
The other one's called Mursick,
it's kind of an opera rock.
It's actually kind of
vampire rock in a way.
I don't think I've heard opera rock.
Like Transylvania and
like, back in the old times
in movies when you hear
all the organ playing
when there's vampires and
like, it's very gothic.
Do you have any pets?
I have three gargoyles in my room.
(crickets chirp)
Pets, man, I have a dog, no gargoyles.
Do you talk to them, do you feed them?
No, I just keep air brushing them.
I paint their nails.
Oh, that's sweet.
We're about to walk into Fabiolus.
Vampire's favorite restaurant.
A lot of garlic, so I gotta be careful.
Unfortunately I love it so they gave me
this pill that I can take.
It's like Lactaid for garlic.
It's dinner time so he
has to take out his fangs.
I gotta take these out because
I don't want to swallow them on accident.
Whoa.
(laughs)
Oh my god.
Wait, so what are you gonna eat?
As long as you're not trying
to drink my blood, I'm happy.
So do you sleep in the day time?
I actually do sleep in a lot.
I work for myself and I have like,
my room is very blacked out.
I am this close to actually
sleeping in a coffin.
And I actually do have a basement.
(high pitched tone)
We got our wonderful dinner.
Steak, of course it's rare
because he loves blood.
(laughter)
And you have, here is
the special of the night
is the handmade gnocchi pesto with shrimp.
Pesto is made from basil,
Parmesan, olive oil,
and pine nuts, oh there's
garlic in it, too, obviously.
I left that out because I'm a vampire.
No, I don't die from garlic.
So we just finished
dinner, it was really good.
Amazing pesto.
He got a lot of garlic today,
I was worried about him but he survived.
Fortunately the wine counteracts
the effects of garlic.
What has been your
fascination with vampires?
Honestly I just don't
believe that they exist.
Or that they're real, I
used to hope they didn't.
I've never seen one, and yet here you are.
Here I am.
Do you usually tell everybody
that you're a vampire?
I kind of stay low key with it.
What vampire really means to me,
is that the music I
write is very gothic and
was inspired by vampire-esque films.
My love of Tim Burton films.
He kind of gave me a really good window
into like the world of vampires, you know.
They're people just like you and me.
Just with fake fangs.
The rooftop was really nice,
we had a view of Los Angeles.
- [Anthony] Really nice chairs.
And so it kind of just was
a great way to end the date.
Was I a good date?
(laughter)
I've heard that before.
Oh no, you were great.
Okay.
You were super fun.
You're super fun!
You have great energy and
that's what's important.
The date tonight was super
fun, I had a great time.
Selorm was a great person,
we had a lot in common.
She's very intrigued by
the whole vampire culture.
Hanging out with Anthony
was kind of an eye opener.
It kind of exposed me
to the fact that this is
really just a community
of people that have
a lot of similar interests.
I think this has really
enhanced my interest
in vampire culture.
First blind date I went on with a vampire
and it was great, he's
a really cool person.
Maybe I'll even get my own pair of fangs.
You will.
Second date.
Getting fangs.
Totally.
(calm music)